for ten years now john stockwell has
been a regular guest on alternative
views we first interviewed John in 1978
after he had quit the CIA and it just
published a book in search of enemies in
which he criticized the 1975 US
operation in Angola which he supervised
a CIA case officer and he provided in
this book his first general critique of
the role of the CIA in u.s. foreign and
domestic policy in interviews with us
over the last 10 years John has
discussed how he joined the CIA and
provided detailed accounts of his
operations in Angola and Africa and
Vietnam and elsewhere in the meantime
John has become a peace activist lecture
author screenwriter and one of the
world's foremost critics of the CIA and
u.s. foreign policy during the entirety
of the 1980's the Reagan years John has
been tireless in his criticism of the
CIA and Reagan's foreign policy and has
lectured and written and spoken out on
these topics literally all over the
world so it is with great pleasure that
we meet with John again today John we
haven't seen you on alternative views
for some time what have you been up to
this year we've tried several times I've
been travelling constantly non-stop
travel it finally wound down for the
lecture stuff about the end of May and
then I took a vacation working on a book
project down south and just got back
into town
lots of interest out there in the world
tremendous I I have invitations to
lecture seven days a week and I just
sort of take what my voice whilst and
deep concern about Central America deep
concern about the arms race deep concern
about the drug problem that's that's
clearly dragging our nation down deeps
concern about the you know the truth of
what our country is all about and and
the values that this country professes I
mean people have it laid out right in
front of them that our government is has
been tolerating and even encouraging
drug traffickers in Central America one
of the key drug traffickers in Panama
Noriega
it was published in Newsweek
magazine saying openly quote the closing
line and the Newsweek article for 10
million people to read Noriega saying
I've got the vice president by the balls
now here you have a key drug mafioso
openly bragging that he has blackmail
control of our of one of the two
presidential candidates now this sort of
thing has to have the nation deeply
concerned the confusion redoubled
however by Ronald Reagan going to Moscow
and hugging and kissing with the evil
empire with Gorbachev and and and
doonesbury writing a thing about the
Cold War being being dead and the
appearance of a ceasefire in Nicaragua
so on the one hand you have people in
the peace community saying we won in
Nicaragua we stopped the destabilization
there President Reagan has been
pressured and led and induced
established from cordial relations with
the Soviet Union and the Cold War is
over so the battles won which is as
untrue and inaccurate as some of the
claims at the right was putting on us on
on the other side and again one of the
two presidential candidates deeply mired
into the the great drug machinery let's
explore this theme for a minute John it
hasn't really been reported on the media
that George Bush according to these
stories at least his office had a drug
ring that was delivering arms to the
Contras and bringing back weapons or
bringing back drugs into the United
States and that Bush's office was thus
connected with crime with Noriega with
drugs etc can you give a little bit of
the detail of this operation of what
this might portend for George Bush's
future as a presidential candidate well
actually the most fascinating thing is
that it has been reported a year and a
half ago when the iran-contra scandal
broke the major media was saying time
and again George Bush is dead in the
water his political career is finished I
mean the New York Times repeatedly the
Washington Post repeatedly because the
information was out of this linkage with
George Bush his key staffers with Felix
Rodriguez
stana nila Pangu who is running the
contra air supply effort which was in
fact flying drugs back up into the
United States Felix Rodriguez was the
man who approached the Medellin
Colombian cocaine cartel to get them to
make a donation to the Contras during
the Boland hiatus - by continuing access
to the airplanes this information was in
a major major media a year and a half
ago but the the tolerance of this nation
conditioned to the sleaze and corruption
and lies and and entire what should be
outrageous activities of oliver north of
the national security council and
blowing off the law illegally smuggling
drugs illegally exporting arms illegally
running wars around the world illegally
trying to assassinate world leaders
bragging about it on one hand and
turning around the next day and denying
it the nation has just become so
incredibly tolerant that that they
didn't close bush down a year and a half
ago and he has managed since he had
control of the republican party machine
and he's the heir apparent as vice
president he's managed to proceed and
emerge as one of the two presidential
candidates now if Dukakis stubs his toe
Bush will be the president with the
leading drug dealers bragging quote
Newsweek
we've got him by the balls they only you
know there was a quote or a story in the
spotlight which just came out today and
it was talking about they have some
information about some intercepts which
the National Security Agency has which
they've been sitting on for some time in
which they have Noriega talking to
people in Noriega talking specifically
about his relationship with Bush and
hand all and how they tied in with a
drugs and the guy is just hit his he
didn't call him a wimp he called him a
pimp and person all the other line said
you mean a whip no I know English I said
pip
well but the I think the key thing that
I saw that somebody pointed out some
analysts said if the US media were
spending as much time on George Bush as
they do on the sex lives of Tammy Bakker
and some of the other right-wing
evangelists then the people would have a
very clear idea about George Bush or if
they'd spent the amount of time on on
George Bush that they spent on Gary Hart
sex life for example but they were
clearly out to destroy Gary Hart and
they did over a matter of sexual
promiscuity which is not that unusual in
Washington believe me among senators and
congressmen and and the world of society
today the drug smuggling unfortunately
see the tolerance of the nation gets
back it's understandable at two levels
you would think that the man the doors
would slam shut on him everywhere you
would think that based on what we know
right up front of the public record that
he would have been impeached and forced
to resign immediately discussions were
held about this year and a half ago that
that made it into the public realm but
he didn't the reason the nation is not
outraged as it should be
as I see it is because at both ends of
the spectrum and in between there's a
tolerance towards drugs and ambivalence
on the bottom and drugs have been
counterculture stuff for a long time the
progressive community the hippies that
you know the as an act of defiance
smoking pot in between you have doctors
and lawyers and business people and the
engineers in Silicon Valley as the ones
who can afford cocaine when the price
was higher now there's been so much
cocaine under the country plus crack at
the price is down then at the ultra end
of the spectrum you're talking about a
hundred and fifty billion dollar
industry now there's no way that our
major banks are going to allow this
money to be deposited in banks on Mars
or in the Soviet Union this is big
business and so they're going to be
sucking the money back into the Machine
as efficiently as possible which they do
through these Cayman Island banks and
Panama
and Panama lol Antonio and San Antonio
and Miami right and the money flows so
the question is where is society going
to go the the capitalists the people who
own the banks who own the capital system
obviously comfortable George Bush
machinery the wheels would turn they
make their money it gets it gets
fascinating taking it to the other end
of the line the third world's revenge if
you will looking at it from the
viewpoint of Latin Americans as long as
the stuff is exported up here it's a
source of hard currency it's a lot
better than selling bananas a lot more
profitable to the United States bringing
hard currency down to their country and
if in fact it damages the US society
there's not a great percentage of people
in Latin America who would be regretful
considering the way we've exploited mark
all of these years getting back to
George Bush is a very important
connection and that is those of us who
study American power structure I have
been following this and that is that
George Bush was the establishment David
Rockefeller etc they were he was their
candidate during the election when
Reagan came in and they forced Bush upon
Reagan Reagan didn't want him now they
found out that of course Bush was a
member of the Trilateral Commission and
then when the right-wingers put heat on
him during the election or the the
attempt to get the nomination within
George Bush quit so will I'm not a
member of the Trilateral Commission
anymore but since then the Trilateral
Commission and the Bilderberg
organization which is even more covert
organization of the International power
structure but once again controlled by
David Rockefeller they reiterated just
the past few days that Bush is their
candidate now they also have people who
are from the establishment media and
they all claim there's no such
organization as a Bilderberg but
particularly the right-wingers they
penetrate these organs
to find out what's going on so this is
one of the main things they have going
for them now they put out the were they
going to support George Bush right down
the line because they're not sure about
Dukakis they know he's an unknown
quantity but so this unit if these
groups control the media this means that
at least as far as CBS and the
television networks are concerned this
story about Bush and his connections
with these drug rings simply might not
penetrate into the public I mean even if
the New York Times or Washington Post as
a story on page ten unless it gets on
the cover of Newsweek and time and on to
the front of the CBS News and is
repeated ten days in a row the story
doesn't have any offense right we have
to remember the Watergate was talked
about before Nixon won the 70s I was
lucky but obviously it was talked about
but what until after you won the
election that the media really got in
there and started digging in plastered
it every day that's that's what's needed
pounded in into people's consciousness
and this this is the big question is
will now Dukakis is leading 51 to 39
over Bush according to what I saw on TV
yesterday and and among women voters
it's 61 39 or something like that the
the question of course is what's going
to happen after the conventions when
they go after each other after they've
resolved the party issues and I I would
think that that we will see some of the
layers being peeled off in that debate
not necessarily because if you
understand that we have a two-party
system but it's two parts of the same
system and and they like the iran-contra
cover-up last summer the the purpose of
that was a bipartisan as a parent
bipartisan function to maintain a public
trust damage control damage control in
which the Democrats allowed the
Republicans to advance their agenda and
the Democrats did not go for the jugular
vein which would have been easy to do to
impeach George Bush and President Reagan
because the system didn't want to lose
the public trust it
it is very possible that Dukakis will
not go for George Bush's throat even at
the at the potential cost of losing the
election well if there's a head enough
in the polls as he is now he doesn't
need to he has plenty of other issues
that he can exploit for one thing Bush
doesn't have any real social base it's
only the Republican country-club set and
multinational capital said that are
really behind him otherwise that even
the right wing in this country has grave
suspicions about Bush they see him as a
Connecticut you know East Coast sort of
Republican moderate which they don't
like absolutely so this is not a popular
candidate he's had very little success
in his speaking and campaigning in terms
of mobilizing support the way Ronald
Reagan was able to then you get into the
question of where where would Dukakis
lead us if he if he does if Bush comes
in he's continuing Reaganomics and he's
continuing covert action and the Secret
Wars he's trying to play the much of the
echo of Ronald Reagan this is a little
ironic and unfortunate when you when you
consider that as was noted many times
Ronald Reagan you know it was said never
had an original idea in his life and
George Bush is coming along trying to
echo Ronald Reagan's ideas such as they
were it puts George Bush pretty far down
the ladder in terms of innovation and
thinking development of programs and
policies but let's take it to the other
side say things go as they seem to be
going and Dukakis wins will that put the
world and it puts it puts the world into
a situation that has me deeply concerned
one of the advantages when Reagan was in
office is the simplistic idealism
outspoken misspeaking
upfront corruptions sleaze turning on
this biggest spending the money it was
an overt evil if you will an overt
mismanagement and overt corruption and
overt brutality what we're facing now is
a situation where the the peace
the people are being lulled if you will
Reagan in his last year has turned smart
Nancy and her astrology or someone you
know they got it worked out by hugging
and kissing with Gorbachev and coming up
with an INF token agreement they got
everyone breathing a sigh of relief and
well you have to say it is better to
have them talking then have them railing
at each other in threatening however
before the INF now the INF agreement
provides for us to withdraw what is it
432 missiles from Europe and the
Russians to take out a bunch of obsolete
SS 20s 1600 or something like that now
the the before this agreement was inked
the the nuclear gang was making its
arguments preparing to build and deploy
two thousand more more sophisticated
weapons in Europe claiming that we were
weakened because of the INF agreement so
what we're facing is quantum leap
forward and in the nuclear you know rush
to nuclear midnight and the peace
movement lulled into quiet by well we
have an agreement elite leaders are
hugging and kissing even if they take
another step forward and go for the
reduction of some of the strategic
missiles it's only to clear the deck so
that they can get money to build some
more they're also saying that the new
generation like you said they were in a
real panic when all this came about and
the Russians kept giving us more and
more I'm giving us giving you more and
more and more until finally we couldn't
refuse yeah because we look really
really bad
so immediately Kissinger and all this
people had a big powwow and they came up
said well you know we need not only a
new generation but we need all kinds of
conventional weapons to defend the
communist threat and these are going to
cost a whole lot more folks so that
means you have blah blah blah blah the
question is whether Dukakis would go
along with these kinds of policies Jesse
Jackson of course has been criticizing
his domestic policies as simply
amounting to a managing of Reaganomics
in other words not carrying out
fundamental economic changes and there's
no evidence so far the Dukakis does have
another economic program other than
managed technocratic managed
tightening the belt trying to work on
the deficit a little bit there are a lot
of parallels between what if you read
the book
Dukakis the man who would be President
which is which is self serve I mean it's
it's an advocacy book but but still
laying out his his mistakes in his
career it's what he's done in
Massachusetts you know he was said he
was swearing he would never raise taxes
he was forced to the state was going
bankrupt but cutting substantially
social programs and the the economic
revival in Massachusetts and Boston
which is pretty real a lot of that's
built on defensemen right Ronald Reagan
made it possible with his military
buildup is exactly managing managing
Reaganomics and profiting from it then
then you get into he you know it's
supposedly liberalism or progressive you
find little things that have to trouble
you know how far he'll go with them I
don't know but a big political effort
early in his career Brookline you know
this this elite residential area that he
grew up in and lives in was being
invaded by you know the cruddy people
who weren't wealthy who weren't plugged
in now Dukakis himself wasn't wealthy
but still he cherished this exclusive
area that he lived in so he was working
very hard to keep the the scumbags out
keep the riffraff out see and this of
course is the principle of immigrants
from the beginning of the United States
once they get in and a second generation
when I graduate from Harvard they want
to keep the others out now what are his
policies going to be for the immigrants
the INF you know that all of these
things that Reagan has been very upfront
about I think we may be in for some some
unfortunate surprises from Dukakis on
these issues well not now that he won't
be pushed by Jesse Jackson he'll go back
to his usual self I think after he had
the nomination sewed up I saw where he
was saying well actually in a lot of
ways I'm more conservative than George
Bush and then I read some analyses of
his years in Massachusetts in the
Guardian and they were saying
same things that you were saying that he
was anti labor anti-gay he was cutting
Social Services and he was making sure
that there weren't any taxes on the
corporations or the wealthy he was just
a mini Reagan in Massachusetts the
flipside of the system you know that's
the truly dumb and tweedle Edie
Twitty will have Twitter ly dumber he
will have the the added or the asset of
he has been fierce on corruption his
whole political be a good honest manager
a squeaky clean he has been fighting
corruption he did work very hard and and
gets a lot of credit for cleaning up a
very rotten political machine in
Massachusetts in Boston and and this
this of course the the nation would
respond to this in welcome this would he
come out real hard on the drug smuggling
and as he as he said on occasion indict
all the people involved and I I'm
skeptical would he rocked the boat that
much i I don't see anything in his past
that if you really get to the bottom of
it to me you've got to clear away the
big banks and the Rockefellers nobody's
going to do that most in yes the most
interesting thing that's going to come
out of the next month will be at the
democratic convention will be to see how
they deal with Jesse Jackson and this
large constituency that he brings in
there by all rights he should be the
vice president if there were any any
popular responsibilities or democracy in
his two-party system we have he has
earned the right at least the vice
presidency
but if he's if he comes in to the vice
presidency of course he'll bring his
progressive agenda there will be a lot
of clashes and I'd be quite they don't
see the establishment can live very well
with Dukakis they're going to have big
problems living with Jackson even if
he's compromising and trying to you know
calm them and reassure them what they
will probably do of course is get a
conservative running mate and then it'll
be interesting to see what they can give
Jackson that will keep him on board
because if they betray him if they cut
him off if they humiliate him
then all of the the 3% whatever it is
that you know that has has supported him
solidly they're not going to vote for
Dukakis and his team in which case
George Bush could wind up to be
president so they need Jackson to win
that they can't concede a lot of the
ideas he wants because it goes against
the grain of their own ideologies the
basic ideology of capitalist control of
the system the power bloc controlling
itself Jackson is a challenge there's
another curiosity about Dukakis and that
is he came out very strongly about doing
away with the u.s. foreign policy in
regard to Nicaragua it's a failed policy
no good we gotta quit supporting the
Contras yet on the other hand he said
that he would not abandon first strike
and a nuclear war seems like kind of a
contradiction here I was so surprised to
see him come out so strongly against the
Contras well Dukakis mind you this
association we've put together we've had
we've been going to primary States and
holding hearings and challenging the
candidates okay and what is your
association it's we call it the
Association for Responsible descent and
it's built around some ex-cia some ex
Defense Department X state X National
Security Council as well as civilian
scholars who are qualified scholars into
the subject and people who've earned
credentials in other ways through
writing or filmmaking or whatnot to be
qualified as experts on the subject of
national security to investigated the
study to educate research and it
tremendous energy in this thing this is
the organization that has finally
brought together given a home in which
people like Daniel Ellsberg Peter Dale
Scott David McMichael Brian Wilson john
stockwell john stockwell yeah the first
organization i've joined since i left
the government they just wasn't an
organization that related to our
interests and yet our interests are
basic to the whole diseased aspect of
our potentially wonderful system and
this this group has been meeting
continuously we've had 10 major
meetings during the year wherever we
could at end states where primaries were
being held challenging the candidates to
come now they're in and out of time very
hard to nail them down but if they
couldn't come to send someone to
articulate their positions and answer
questions and challenges from us and
what we got out of Dukakis it was useful
we did make them articulate positions on
quote national security and covert
policies and secrecy and whatnot you met
with Dukakis or some of his with some of
us met with Dukakis and we had formal
public hearings in which he sent key
aides to articulate his line Anna Simon
Jackson the other time we were doing
this way back in Iowa and since what
Dukakis said we dropped the others
because there they're out of it although
at one point last January some of
Jackson's advisers were beginning to say
well a little bit of covert action and
we got oh yeah and we got we nailed and
we stopped that by saying you know you
can't have a little bit of that you know
if if Jackson and they were saying well
we need a more moderate image so we
don't scare people off and we said we
won't put up with that if Jesse Jackson
moderates and compromises on his
sympathy and protective position towards
the third world then he will be
absolutely chopped off by the
progressive community in the world he
will not be allowed to compromise and
they very quickly dropped that line
now what Dukakis said was was actually
you know applause on his side I would
say encouraging he was in Peru you know
he speaks excellent Spanish he was in
Peru as a young man working when the
Guatemalan operation was run as he has
said himself in public speeches he
personally felt the humiliation of
seeing his country engineered the
overthrow of a functioning
constitutional democracy in Latin
America for for the profit of the United
Fruit Company this was 1953 1954 and he
said repeatedly and his staffers
maintain that if he's elected president
there will be no more chilies and
Guatemalans as he put
so then you tell you know okay what
about Angola what about Chad what about
Ethiopia will he cut up all covert
actions and what they do now I get part
at that point he said well I'm against
the Contras and you'd ask about Angola
and he'd say well we'll have to study
each part of the world but dukakis his
people just keep coming back and saying
there will be no more
Guatemala's and no more Chile and then
you say well what about the El
Salvadorian election manipulation
campaign will those things be outlawed
as well and they say there will be no
more chiles and no more Guatemalans now
this is encouraging now if you add that
to if you will the results of our
efforts over over the is yours
alternative use mind lecturing and the
community at large we've accomplished
some interesting things bill Colby my
old boss who ran the Phoenix program in
Vietnam that he says killed 22,000
people has come out saying that the CIA
should be gotten out of the corporate
action business fall together hold it
it's called a head of the CIA
oh yes yes CIA director yeah he's been
well what what chart what change that
because I've seen him on TV or you know
he's not the air - I shouldn't do these
things he said he's saying that the CI
should because it being an intelligence
agency rather than an action agency yeah
William Webster who's the new director
who's saying he hasn't said this is my
policy this is what I'm working towards
but he said that that we should examine
the possibility of getting the CI out of
covert action altogether
well then where they're not saying there
wouldn't be covert action or saying get
the CIA out is apathy just sort of fre
they stopped their comment at that point
now the the presumption of course is
that that the stuff would be done by the
Defense Department and the Green Berets
and they would do the covert wars and
the CI would gather intelligence now
this would in fact be a healthy step for
the nation for one thing we might have a
chance of getting some good intelligence
if the CI wasn't having to justify its
own Wars of course the danger would be
transferring to the Pentagon generals in
charge and having them out there trying
to overthrow
governments and why not if that happens
now if Dukakis came into office and
pursued his policy about Guatemala's and
chiles and if Webster would play ball
and the community mind you the block of
CI pros inside who would like to go home
and feel proud in front of their 20 year
old college daughters who have just seen
a film about conscience slitting throats
you know in Nicaragua and and you know
daddy are you in the CIA you know I mean
this is a real problem for CI officers
there is a block of people inside the CI
and there has been all along that have
been saying we would like to be an
honorable organization we've been
betrayed by people who want to go out
and pay people to cut throats we should
gather intelligence and do it well
now if events evolve and let's big if if
George Bush comes in just forget all of
this and if Dukakis comes in put a big
question mark on it but if it did evolve
in this direction then we would run into
a restructuring and a lot of political
infighting would the CI really give up
all capability would they just give up
most of it but retain a little unit that
would do some things and then if you got
it into the Pentagon
they don't have stations in every
embassy around the world this is how the
CI is managed to hang on to this
capability the other people don't have
the way to send telegrams the
infrastructure people train people
speaking languages to do this all over
the world so what you would see would be
a restructuring of the DIA the Defense
Intelligence Agency with it being built
up at least in key countries that they
wanted to destabilize around the world
and see a shifting of these activities
from one department to another with
perhaps the CI winding up a different
kind of an organization but the big
question is would you know would in fact
the United States policy change one iota
and my suggestion is that that that like
this I enough agreement we we have not
stuck we're still you know cranking out
five bombs a day and and the Soviet
Union is
and as you know putting out bombs and
more sophisticated ones all the time
plus all these other nations that are
trying to reach some level of parity in
the mad principle mutually assured
destruction
exactly by 1992 the British and the
French can combined or it's estimated
this is not solid figures that we've
been able to document but about a 1200
deliverable strategic thermonuclear
weapons between them we'll see that's
enough to destroy the world either one
of them and so that would put them into
the mad category they could destroy us
as we could destroy them the French
could destroy us as we could destroy
them so other nations coming into the
level of the club the inner membership
the upper membership where they could
also destroy the world or trigger events
that would destroy the world now while
we're celebrating the INF agreement the
factories are turning out these these
weapons of destruction at the same pace
they have throughout so the peace
movement vigilant and active we have to
redouble efforts and it's going to be it
is harder and it's going to be harder as
Reagan and Gorbachev I got the sense of
alarm of imminent danger that surely
much easier when President Reagan was
was railing at the evil empire and
saying you can always drop some test
bombs in Europe show them we mean
business that's up front I mean you
would want in the peace movement to have
a president that was that gauche just
because it makes your case so easy to
make I I've been on TV shows and radio
shows including one yesterday in which
someone was railing at me over the air
saying you know I was way out of touch
you know they've got an agreement going
and why was I a die-hard and everything
and yet nothing has changed they're
going to pull back 432 weapons from
Europe now this person was saying see
you've got to get tough we have to have
an asset with the Soviets before we can
bargain now we had 30,000 thermonuclear
weapons before Reagan came into office
you know we had a major asset we had
enough to destroy 50 or 60 Soviet
Union's all together he came up with
this program that
at mellorak published and gave the
budgetary figures for and everything
began before he came into office and he
pursued it and sold it made it effective
to build and employ 17,000 more
thermonuclear weapons he put the 400
Pershing 's and intermediate weapons in
Europe and then we come up with the
program to the INF agreement to
dismantle the delivery systems and take
the bombs back home and the Soviets as
part of the agreement pull out of their
SS 20s which were obsolete anyway which
they don't mean they can with their
longer range missiles devastate your
employees land very effectively but the
quantum increase the gross increase for
the world of course is what if we got 30
some-odd percentage increase in our
thermo nuclear capability under Ronald
Reagan and the Soviets likewise plus
these other nations coming on board and
anyone go ahead now well the point is
that they're claiming see this is a
vindication of what Reagan said when he
came into office he said you have to get
tough build up your military to get the
Russians to talk so I got tough I built
up the military and I got them to sign
an agreement the first agreement that's
ever been made that were they we really
dismantled weapons but the fact is what
is it what is 400 out of 40,000 it was
1% I mean they're getting rid of a tiny
little percentage of what of weapons it
didn't exist when they came into office
it's a daughter I don't I'm more than
that it's an utter fraud get them to go
back and reduce a tiny percentage of
them of obsolete weapons meanwhile the
Russians are coming out with their SS
eighteens and emerged SS 18s and and the
other evolutions of weaponry which which
clearly make the world exponentially
more dangerous at the end of the Reagan
era despite the sign of agreement howdy
and this Daniel Ellsberg said back when
Jimmy Carter was in office we have a
tape of a speech he gave here of course
he was a former defense analyst himself
at the RAND Corporation he said if you
want a deterrent you only need two
submarines yes because each of them can
wipe out the major cities in the Soviet
Union
trying to go back to Dukakis what is his
policy on nuclear weapons and relations
with the Soviet Union there hadn't been
too much on that in the media well he's
been faulted for making some some fairly
basic statements at the level of first
strike capability and bargain with the
Soviets which which which were in fact
naive which weren't in fact simplistic
and gave ammunition to the other side
that he has no experience in this field
he's saying basically we have to pursue
vigorously in arms agreement and get rid
of 50% of the strategic weapons and it
is it is awkward because that I mean
that's wonderful 50% is half the number
that could malfunction and trigger World
War 3 and the obliteration of the planet
but it still leaves enough to utterly
destroy 10 planets meanwhile the
factories are still it gets back to the
Jonathan Schell book the fate of the
earth you know you can get rid of all
the weapons but you've still got the
factories turning out weapons you get
rid of the you close down the factories
but you've still got the technical
capability so you know that would be a
wonderful first step but it would be
meaningless
unless we shut the factories down well
what about testing military spending
weapons development with Dukakis has he
committed himself to significant
restraints in this area or is he just
not taking a clear position yet I have
seen no commitment from him on cutting
back on on them on the Don the defense
and the reassurance and no implied
reassurance you try to strip the strip
away the rhetoric and the glib things
that they all say I'm for peace you know
wanna know this he is not beating the
drums of a big defense program but if
you look what at what he did in
Massachusetts cutting cutting welfare
cutting the social program selling out
the progressive community if you will in
interests of the people for the the
capitalist system for the common good
it does not give you any great assurance
that he's going to go after the military
machine he probably will go after
corruption now one thing that he it was
just you know yesterday and the news is
Bush was was bashing him on tax
increases and Dukakis was saying that he
would solve the tax problem by really
vigorous laws to recover taxes that are
not being paid as opposed to cutting
back military spending that could solve
the national deficit two years if they
just stopped producing weapons yeah
cutting back on the military spending
and also going after the the rich the
higher income brackets that don't pay as
a problem today daughter cause who our
he's going to be going after you know
the great you know the people across the
nation who are a little loose on paying
this and paying that and and try to
launch a reform at that level without
doing anything at least but that's the
indication we don't know for sure but
that's the indication I see that's what
I'm concerned John can I ask you a other
question about George Bush uh to a lot
of people he's is kind of mealy-mouthed
you know when he doesn't seem to have
much substance to him but he was head of
the CIA
how long was he head of the CIA and did
he have any personal impact on it and to
the CIA change direction in any way when
he was head of it yeah he had he had
about a year in the CIA I worked for him
he you know you know in the Angolan
operation President Ford fired bill
Colby in November and then suddenly
realized that we were still in the
process of the Senate hearings and Colby
was right in you couldn't change
Directors in the middle of the hearings
and we were in the middle of the Angola
war and the Congress was very upset
about this war and so he announced
without consulting Colby they released
it to the paper that he had been fired
and then that was on a Friday on a
Monday they had to go back and ask him
if he would stick around for another
couple of months and only a good soldier
of his caliber
would have agreed anyone else in the
world would have said sorry babe you
know I just read in the paper I was
fired and enough is enough but he agreed
and he stuck it out and he took the heat
and then when the program was stopped by
the Congress a Tony amendment passed on
the 18th of December and 75 and then we
got into it took you know six weeks for
them to sign it into law
they brought George Bush in and he
inherited the job of fending off the
hostile Congress and this was where I
worked for him now was not in his office
I didn't work close with him but
nevertheless he was the director and we
had a real rotten apple in this Angola
thing because we had lied to the
Congress we committed perjury we had
broken the law and the Congress was very
angry and they had the ammunition about
to shut us down and to end to Jayla
certainly it had all of the potential
dimensions of the iran-contra scandal
and and his job the Congress didn't want
another Watergate sized scandal and so
the if they if they could be persuaded
they would and he inherited the job
anyway what we found was first he came
into office and it led to a lot of
joking because of this factor the wimp
factor that this Rufus Shalit e of the
phone enos of the man he he was from the
first day he got there he put out a memo
saying you know how wonderful it was to
be on board this wonderful organization
with all these wonderful people yeah and
then every three days we would get
another memo would go throughout the
entire building telling us how wonderful
we were and you know the sophisticated
people this is this is childish its its
campaign rhetoric kind of stuff he would
also we had in the CIA I mean these
people you know they go up and down they
run around they go to meetings across
the directors and you'd find yourself
sometime on the elevator with the
director or down in the gym with the
director and kind of you know this was
him and they had their space and you
sort of you know stood your side of the
elevator and kept your mouth shut but
Bush would walk down the hall shaking
hand I hello I'm George Bush and I want
you to know I think this is a wonderful
innovation
and I'm really happy to be here and I
really love working with people like you
what's your name and which just it just
didn't work you know he was campaigning
right there in the halls it didn't work
to gain anyone's respect one thing that
came out of it apparently and
reconstructing all of the details will
never be done history will never give us
this unless someone involved writes a
good book and I don't think they will in
this case but it was during his tenure
that there was the bombing in Washington
circling in Washington Orlando Letelier
and running Moffitt by some some CI
people from the operation Mongoose the
project-40
destabilization of Cuba and he's people
were Chileans who had been with a yen
day government Chileans but also Cuban
exiles who right we're in X X it was the
operation was run by the Chileans Dina
but people were actually involved were
from this Cuban exile community now this
was the community that had worked for
about four intense years under Kennedy
and then Johnson and then johnson shut
it down to destabilize Fidel's cuba in
the early days of their revolution and
then johnson cut it all now when johnson
it was bloody it was a big one Cronkite
did a show on it dan Rather did a show
on it years later it was it was hundreds
and hundreds of sorties and boat raids
flown and you know burning crops swine
fever and hog population bombs and
department stores white phosphorus
grenades in schools kidnapping and
murder it was a really vicious thing now
blowing up airplane blowing up airplanes
absolutely now when these people were
cut off by the CIA under Johnson under
his orders they they were set free with
all their skills but also with the
tolerance of the entire Florida legal
structure who had been warned off all
these years well this is CIA national
security
you let that boat of arms go through and
of course those boats of arms began to
go and come with drugs so when they were
cut off they had the skills the Train
the violence and the license and they
immediately became a big mafia in
Florida and went into murdering and
bombing and killing and and then taking
it up to New York bombing and bombing
trying to bomb the Cuban mission trying
to bomb the United Nations lots of
bombings and killings this one Dubois
shoe just came back into the country had
been caught trying to fire a bazooka at
a Polish freighter they had tasks for
setup to study this crime problem of the
Cuban exiles and concluding that it was
virtually unsolvable during Bush's
tenure the CIA cut a deal with these
people saying enough is enough but
political you simply have to get out of
the country to keep this tank cool it
inside the United States and they went
out of the country in September of 76
and had this meeting in the Bahamas
where they form this carew organization
which one month later in October blew up
the Cubano airliner I was taking off
from Barbados that had the fencing team
in santiago santiago alvarez wife and
child a filmmakers wife and child on and
76 other people now this deal the
contacts that were made with bush with
these people at that time Rhea Rhea
Pierre when he has Don Gregg on his
staff as vice president with Felix
Rodriguez who was a ranking member of
that Cuban community who was with Don
Gregg in Vietnam and then you have
chichi Quintero and the others working
with with Rodriguez in the Contra
program and George Bush's son down in in
in Florida going on television literally
arm in arm in December of 85 literally
arm in arm with ten X's from this Cuban
exile destabilization of Cuba program so
this apparently is where George Bush da
feat Ivy Leaguer got plugged into that
mafia and they got their hooks into him
made the contacts that led eventually
the situation where today one of them
Noriega is able to say I have George
Bush by the ball
see this mind you mind you the CIA had
Noriega on on its payroll 200,000 he was
g2 of the army and Omar Torrijos died in
a mysterious plane crash and Noriega
becomes the leader of the country my
guess we do not have this confirmed we
do have it confirmed that the CI had him
on a payroll now my guess is that at
that time if it was not plotted by the
CIA or plotted by Noriega himself
killing and Torrio's so Noriega could
take power however that happened in
detail some CI case officers were
writing very high in their little office
of the CIA because their agent was now
in charge of Panama what evolve past
that though of course is Noriega has
personality of his own and eventually
he's dealing with the Colombians he's
dealing with Cuba and he's dealing with
Israel and everybody else and eventually
began to break the break the sea ice
roads and others rules until eventually
they turned on him to indict him he was
sorry too many drugs on his own well the
selling of the drugs that's been done by
people working for the CIA since World
War two the kun min OSS station in China
was actually paying its bills with
heroin and then the the cumin tang that
the China adds all those planes that
were flying into de Beth and Burma and
back into Taiwan that was part that was
a subsidy of the Taiwanese economy that
was part of why Taiwan flourished a lot
of US aid a lot of ingenuity on their
part in building factories in one Hut
and a steady influx of big heroin drug
money with the CIA's Air American before
that the civil air transport flying the
stuff for them are the truth going to
come out on this issue is there going to
be more focus on it or is this just
going to disappear like Watergate we
still don't know what happened Watergate
I know I think absolutely the
iran-contra cover-up last summer this is
the proper title it's not the
iran-contra joint Committees of the
Congress it's the iran-contra cover-up
that they had a damage control problem
had they done their duty to this nation
and to the law and to justice there is
not a shadow of a doubt President Reagan
would have been impeached and George
Bush would have been impeached even now
there's a possibility if George Bush
doesn't win the presidency that he could
wind up in jail because if he gets some
way if there's no ed Meese in there
protecting their agenda then you know if
you put in a real Attorney General who
started encouraging the attorneys to
pursue these things you bet you're going
to wind up with some prosecutions
I think Dukakis will will go to great
lengths to avoid going for the jugular
they do not want to lose the people's
credibility they the Democrats they do
caucus to lose the people's trust in the
way they would if they brought out the
whole truth and impeached Reagan and
jail George Bush and I assume that
you're a Dukakis supporter instead of
the WAMP right
Oh still Jackson well I'm I'm a jackson
supporter at this point and I will
probably vote this time for Dukakis
against Bush I did not vote for Mondale
I could not vote for him because he
advocated arms and he advocated the
Contra program in Central America and
for whatever it was worth I could not
vote for him what Dukakis does visa V
Jackson and our agenda what I call the
NPR listeners in this country the people
who think and read and study the
alternative views watch the alternative
views much better absolutely now these
these people in this country are
represented most closely by Jackson and
and if Dukakis spurns us and puts in a
senator Bentsen as a running mate or
someone yet more conservative and chops
us off then there's going to be a
decision time what will Jackson do will
he play ball this time and stick with
the Democratic Party or would he perhaps
split off next time
around and launched a third party even
this time now he obviously couldn't get
it going this time in time enough to
have a major impact but see the
Democratic Party there's nothing
democratic about our system are very
little I mean they teach us this in
school we talk about democracy all the
time but even back in grade school
remember where they told you we don't
you know it's a republic
you know we vote for electors who select
the president and the two parties
control 95% of the votes and of the
election process and they structure the
laws to make sure that they control it
now you do have primaries which sort out
the candidates but you also have on the
Democratic side for example the six
hundred odd super-delegates who are not
yet me we're not voted by anyone they're
just party hacks they have no more claim
to to popular to democratic you know
vote nobody's voted for a mate they have
no more claim to represent the people
then do the party hacks and the soviet
union who go in there and vote they come
from a region they're the head of the
party unit in that region so they get a
vote and that's a big boy at six hundred
votes if that you know if it were broken
down to one person one vote in the
primary system instead of the fact what
is it six hundred to one the impact of
votes in texas depending on whether you
come from the wrong part of houston or
rich ranching county in another part of
texas your vote in the primaries has
that much difference in clout and effect
and impact how's that can you explain
yeah because because of this is what
jackson was challenging and railing
about in nineteen eighty four was the
fact that the votes are not allocated
fairly he was trying to get a reduced
reduced it's the old gerrymandering
thing the system has been rigged very
carefully to make sure that the right
parts of town have the most impact at
more delegates
oh they sixty votes and in a wealthy
part of town will equal one delegate six
thousand votes on the wrong side of town
only for one delegate and that's across
the nation now jackson has cooled it on
this issue in nineteen eighty eight
in 1984 he was pounding away on this
issue get the votes distributed fairly
and see what a difference it would make
raises us from time to time as well as a
super delegate issue had the the
electoral or the delegate count been
closer between Jackson Dukakis had they
got in even or even with Jackson ahead
these super delegates would have easily
taken it to the targets because they're
the established near these steps and
well you see this is what Pat Reuter
decided not to run before she said the
system didn't permit her to run and this
is what she was talking about she'd been
traveling from state to state meeting
with the party machinery and the party
machinery was saying no there's not any
chance on the face of the earth that we
will support you we've made that
decision and so she came to the
conclusion and then she was assessing
how much money she could raise she could
raise a little money but not enough to
overpower the party and make the party
accept her so she had to decide not to
run on business decision well who knows
if Jackson been present you might have
been next head of the CIA no way you
could have shut it down week ago what I
sincerely hope will come out of this if
Dukakis does not include Jackson as vice
president is that Jackson will pull out
and give us another party they're
estimating by the turn of the century
one third of every citizen of this
country will be of the so-called
minorities if you take that and their
interests added into their perceptions
added into the the alternative views
Watchers the NPR listeners we might very
well come up with a party that would be
strong enough to reverse the system the
system itself to make a major impact on
the whole structure of US political
society